[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv 60,18
nouvelle édition spéciale en ce
lendemain d'élections vous le savez si
vous nous avez suivi hier soir sur nos
réseaux sociaux le département yvelinois
tout comme la région ile-de-france reste
détenu par la droite et par le centre
dans un instant tous les détails et
toutes les réactions pour le moment deux
chiffres celui de l'abstention dans les
yvelines pour les départemental 64 77 %
et celui de l'île de france
l'abstention toujours pour les
régionales 66,74 % comme dans le reste
de la france les électeurs ont donc
boudé les urnes
bonsoir patrice soit dans un instant je
vous demanderais ce qu'il faut penser de
cette abstention assistons à un accident
à démocratique ou alors une crise plus
profonde de l'être des institutions
républicaines nous verrons ça dans
quelques instants auparavant je vous
propose d'écouter ses yvelinois travers
le département
nous leur avons demandé s'ils étaient
allés voter et surtout pourquoi je sors
juste du bureau d'autres j'ai voté
aujourd'hui parce qu'il faut quand même
que les citoyens
s'occupe un peu de ce qui se passe de ce
qui se passe chez eux quand même ça fait
cinquante ans que je vote donc pourquoi
pas continuer à donner le droit de vote
quoi qu'on fasse on est tenu de voter et
non parce que je suis en vacances pour
le week-end et que du coup j'avoue que
j'ai un petit peu mis de côté les
élections que j'ai pas pensé parce que
je trouve que ce sera rien on sait même
pas si voter ça sert vraiment à quelque
chose
donc voilà pour moi oui ça sert à rien
il ya des élections faut voter sinon
après on peut pas se permettre de
critiquer je vois que les choses
changent je crois tout est pareil tout
temps il ya aucune changement donc ça
sert à rien d'aller goûter en tant que
vingtenaires en fait j'ai aucune
connaissance tout ce qui est en fait au
niveau politique a partout ce qui est
présidentielle et municipales c'est tout
ce que je connais en fait on n'explique
pas vraiment aux jeunes qu est ce qui
est tout ce qui est départementale et
régionale
oui c'est important de faire entendre sa
voix et de effectivement de s'investir
et de s'impliquer dans la politique
j'ai quand même pris conscience que la
semaine dernière j'avais pas été voté et
franchement moins de 20% de des lecteurs
c'est pas possible donc voilà temps je
me suis un peu motivés et on a été votée
patrice malgré les appels à la
mobilisation de la part des élus
l'abstention est restée très forte pour
ce second tour aussi bien pour les
départementales que les régionales oui
c'est vrai que tout ce qui a été dit
cette semaine on a même entendu marine
le pen engueuler un peu ses électeurs
dans sa servi à rien et une abstention
qui gigantesque le qui atteint toutes
les classes d'art d'ailleurs et toutes
les classes sociales toutes les classes
d'âge
il ya que les plus de 70 ans qui sont
allés voter les jeunes n'y vont pas donc
c'est une abstention gigantesque qu'on
dit 65% à 65 % c'est un peu abstrait si
aucune savent être 30 millions de
français qui sont pas allés voter ce qui
comme énergie durable à quoi est due
cette abstention est ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer alors on a entendu dans le
don de me contre peuple a expliqué cyril
ceux qui disent ça se complique que j'y
comprends rien je pas pour qui je vote
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'avoir mêler
les régionales départementales ça
complique un peu les choses c'est vrai
que on pourrait peut-être moderniser un
peu les procédures de vente il faut
toujours aller dans son bureau
de vote peut être que ça il va falloir
quand même un peu le moderniser mais il
ya plus grave y aller il ya une vraiment
une crise démocratique dans cette
abstention au fond il ya deux éléments
un peu contradictoire il ya ceux qui
disent on les a vu ça ça ne veut pas ça
sert à rien et puis il ya aussi j'ai
d'autres abstentionnistes une sorte
d'appel au secours de dire il faudrait
plus de démocratie et quand vous ajoutez
les deux ça fait beaucoup mais c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que les
grands mouvements sociaux qu'on a vu ces
dernières années
prenez des gilet jaune par exemple c'est
vrai que ça ne se traduit pas
politiquement il n'y a pas de partie de
ces jeunes quand ils se présentent ils
font des scores assez minable donc il ya
une autre une autre forme d'engagement
qui n'est pas l'engagement politique et
au fond les élections qui sont censés
réduire un peu les fractures dans une
une société ne joue plus vraiment leur
rôle est ce qu'on peut avoir des
enseignements tirés des enseignements
politiques est ce qu'on peut se projeter
la présidentielle aujourd'hui on entendu
de nombreux candidats
valérie pécresse par exemple xavier
bertrand dire ça y est maintenant on est
déjà lancée sur la campagne
présidentielle dès ce matin peut-être
qu'ils s'avancent un peu rapidement
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils auraient été
bien bien d'élus bien réélu mais au fond
si on regarde ils ont été élus avec
moins de voix qu'il y en avait eu la
dernière en 2015 donc ce qu'est la vraie
la vraie leçon de ce scrutin c'est que
c'est le statu quo les régions qui
étaient à droite reste à droite et
régions qui étaient à gauche reste à
gauche il n'y a pas de billets pas il
n'y a pas de changement
alors il ya peut-être une droitisation
de la société c'est possible mais est ce
que la droite sera en profiter et quand
valérie pécresse dit ça fera peut-être
une équipe de france de la droite et du
centre qui est née oui mais enfin pour
l'instant
elle a au moins trois capitaines sont
fait de trop donc il va y avoir une une
question de la carnation qui sera à
porte haute dans les semaines les mois
qui viennent continuez le parallèle avec
une équipe de france il faut gérer les
ego aussi dans les vestiaires dans ces
cas là pas de projection pour 2022 la
projection vendredi 30 millions
d'abstentionnistes
on peut penser qu'elle aura au moins 15
ou 20 millions qui sont pas déplacés ce
coup-ci qui vont aller voter c'est cela
qui va falloir aller convaincre et vous
allez voir
tout donné dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent je pense que marine le pen
va peut-être radicaliser après son
discours
emmanuel macron lui va se lancer dans
ses dents des réformes parce que au fond
il sait qu'on peut pas être réélu en
france si on pas de risques et je prends
qu'il va prendre tous les risques
merci beaucoup patrice abstention ou pas
en tout cas les urnes ont donc livré
leur verdict pour ces régionales en
ile-de-france et valérie pécresse pour
la droite et le centre qu'ils
l'emportent l'avait emporté d'une courte
tête en 2015 face à la gauche cette fois
ci les quarts en tout cas en pourcentage
est beaucoup plus large et confirme donc
cette nouvelle couleur politique de la
région
dorénavant à droite avant l'arrivée de
valérie pécresse elle a été à gauche
pendant plus de 17 ans à nicolas landry
en tout cas revient sur ce résultat
d'hier soir il est 20h30 au qg de
valérie pécresse des premières
estimations tombent
la présidente sortante de la région
ile-de-france est donnée gagnante face à
l'union de la gauche au rassemblement
national et à la république en marche
d'abord par notre fermeté notre
attention aux territoires ruraux nous
avons fait baisser le rassemblement
national par notre clarté nous avons
fait gagner les forces de la droite et
du centre dans une région où la majorité
présidentielle avait décidé d'engager
cinq ministres par notre incarnation
d'une écologie des résultats nous avons
prouvé que l'écologie n'appartenait à
aucun camp très clairement
valérie pécresse est aujourd'hui celle
qui va conduire les lefranc seul qui a
aussi apporté un certain nombre de
chevaux pays le résultat est confirmé
dans la soirée à 45 92 % avec un écart
de 12 points face à la liste de l'union
de la gauche la droite et le centre
accroît son avance par rapport à 2015
club résultat de ce soir c'est vraiment
la preuve que même dans une région qui
est difficile mais dans une région qui a
été gagné de peu en 2015 qui a connu une
alternance qu on le résume les résultats
sont là les électeurs restent fidèles et
son fidèle et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les que l'écart soit aussi est net et
bien c'est vraiment une
une validation de ce travail qui a été
fait pendant cinq ans dans une région je
le redis qui est difficile normalement
pour la droite dont je crois que valérie
pécresse fait une prouesse ce soir par
ce travail quand voilà on a des
résultats on tient ses promesses de
campagne
on l'a fait avec celle de 2015 et bien
les électeurs le reconnaissent ils
reconnaissent le bilan qui a été fait
ils reconnaissent qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de travail à accomplir ils
veulent nous renouvellent leur confiance
pour continuer ces transformations dans
tout un tas de secteurs sur l'emploi et
la relance économique dans l'écologie
les transports les lycées à 21h15 la
présidente réélue de la région ile de
france quitte son qg direction un hôtel
du xviiième arrondissement
une soirée organisée dans cet
établissement pour célébrer sa victoire
avec ses colistiers et l'ensemble des
membres de la campagne électorale ce
deuxième mandat ça va être celui de la
concrétisation du tout une série
d'investissements qu'on a lancé que ce
soit dans l'iss et qu'ils soient dans
les transports que ce soit en matière en
matière économique
on va en matière d'emploi en matière de
formation on va avec ce deuxième mandat
pouvoir encore en vie fils ce qu'on a
fait si le travail de ce deuxième mandat
commence dès aujourd'hui une autre
échéance électorale et dans les esprits
la présidentielle de 2022 malgré
l'abstention ce double scrutin régional
départemental permet de tirer des
enseignements
en réalité en vue de 2022 il n'y a pas
uniquement emmanuel macron et marine le
pen et que le match est beaucoup plus
ouvert ce soit c'est aussi la preuve que
désormais pour la droite et le centre
c'est un match à trois vous a pas
échappé que valérie pécresse a toujours
été une femme politique nationale
qu'elle avait beaucoup de choses à dire
et que sa victoire est aussi le signe
que lorsqu'on est ferme sur les valeurs
de la république
lorsqu'on obtient des résultats les
français vous sont reconnaissants ils
vous en savent gré donc peut-être que
c'est aussi un bon présage pour l'avenir
mais avant de se pencher sur le
rassemblement de sa famille politique en
vue de l'élection présidentielle
valérie pécresse a rendez vous le
vendredi 2 juillet 2021 pour
l'installation du nouveau conseil
régional
la gauche qui s'incline donc à nouveau
ps europe écologie et les filles n'ont
pas réussi pendant l'entre-deux-tours à
séduire de nouveaux électeurs aucune
progression du score bonsoir eléonore
nous allons revenir avec vous sur ce
scrutin régional en ile de france pour
justement cette liste de gauche et les
quelques sièges finalement obtenu en
effet même 53e moules frites pour
l'union
de la gauche voilà la récompense pour
cette deuxième place obtenue lors du
second tour des élections régionales en
ile-de-france la liste le rassemblement
pour l'écologie et la solidarité
mené par julien bayou secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
n'a pas réussi à détrôner la présidente
sortante de la région valérie pécresse
le score est néanmoins honorable 33 68%
contre 45,92 % pour la liste ile de
france rassemblée pour rappel à l'issue
du premier tour la liste indépendante de
julien bayou s'était classé 3e sur six
listes pour se maintenir au second tour
devant celle d'audrey pulvar parti
socialiste 5e et celle de clémentine
autain la france insoumise 6e
il avait alors décidé de se rassembler
pour le second tour créant une liste
unique notamment pour contrer le
rassemblement national arrivé deuxième
au premier tour et pour tenter de battre
valérie pécresse objectif à demi rempli
donc le rassemblement national étant
arrivé en troisième position lors de ce
second tour au soir des résultats
julien bayou était tout de même
satisfait de ce score se soit vraiment
je crois qu'on a on a réussi quelque
chose d'assez inédit et qui qui insuffle
un bel espoir avec clémentine autain et
audrey pulvar on a on a mis le projet au
coeur l'écologie les solidarités
c'est ça qui nous rassemble le cap on
l'a ce soir ça n'a pas suffi bien sûr
valérie pécresse l'emportent avec des
salles méthode un des anathèmes des
insultes des injures des faits que news
démontage mais l'espoir est là et ce que
nous avons construit en ile de france
nous allons poursuivre et avec la
déclaration de julien bayou longtemps le
climat sera électrique l'ambiance sera
électrique au sein du conseil régional
on l'imaginé bien pour clémentine autain
toutefois élus dans le département de
seine saint denis cette union était une
aubaine pour ces élections
objectif faire front commun aux
prochaines présidentielles
je trouve que nous avons réussi à
agglomérer nos forces et aux fonds
acquis
annick et un espoir donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya cette ambiance ici c'est je
crois que chacun chacune mesures que
nous avons réussi quelque chose qui sans
doute est un point d'appui pour l'avenir
alors si on regarde un peu plus en
détails pour le département des yvelines
se sont assis colistiers de la gauche
qui vont siéger à la région
exactement 6 sièges et deux d'entre eux
seront occupés par ghislaine ce n'est
d'europe écologie les verts
elle était déçue mais optimiste hier
soir au soir des résultats et un autre
par benoît hamon de génération qui lui
était plutôt incisif et revanchard c'est
un rendez vous malheureusement manqué
mais d'un autre côté il faut quand même
se se dire que la question écologique la
question de l'urgence écologique
manifestement confirme le fait que de
plus en plus de personnes se rendent
compte que c'est un vrai sujet et on a
malgré tout consolider en tout cas une
base très très forte de personnes qui
aujourd'hui met l'écologie au coeur de
leurs préoccupations comme madame
pécresse sera pas candidate aux
présidentielles parce qu'elle a fait un
beau coup plus mauvais score que
monsieur wauquiez et et monsieur
bertrand d'ailleurs je le souhaite pas
la droite ni à la république donc mais
pendant six ans va lui je pense que le
conseil régional d'ile-de-france va
regardez à la virgule près e
sa fidélité aux principes républicains
je peux vous dire qu'on va pas la lâcher
qu'on va lui montrer ce que c'est
l'intensité démocratique quoi qu'il en
soit la majorité de valérie pécresse
devra compter sur la gauche et les
écologistes dans l'opposition du conseil
régional on l'a bien entendu rien n'est
moins sûr qu'ils seront se faire un
temps miss ried
au lendemain de ces élections régionales
l'union fait la force mais jusqu'à tout
au moins jusqu'aux présidentielles ou en
tout cas après les présidentielles merci
au nord à deux autres formations se
présentait en ile-de-france le
rassemblement national et la république
en marge de formation qui ratent leur
pari pire le parti présidentiel termine
sous la barre symbolique des 10% et
n'enverra que très peu d'élus dans
l'hémicycle elle toute seule réaction
avec ce reportage de grégory canal est
préparé avec nos confrères de radio
sensations c'était le duel au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle de
2017 ce sont les deux grands perdants de
la soirée le rassemblement national et
la république en marche se classe 3e et
4e des régionales en île de france
le rn obtient 10 79% des voix 32 mille
bulletins en moins par rapport au
premier tour et perd du terrain par
rapport à 2015 à l'instar des autres
régions le parti disposait de 22 sièges
sous la précédente mandature à la région
ce sera 16 sur les six prochaines années
première explication de la tête de liste
jordan bardella l'abstention record qui
s'élèvent en ile-de-france à plus de 66%
en ile de france comme ailleurs la
réélection par défaut et dans un désert
démocratique de la présidente de région
valérie pécresse doit appeler chacun à
la modestie devons nous résoudre à
mettre que la france aura été
indifférente à ce double scrutin
illisible désorganisée et certainement
trop loin d'un peuple épris de liberté
retrouvée
lassé d'un an et demi de vie sous
tutelle j'accueille les résultats de ce
soir avec humilité recul également
confirmé dans les yvelines avec un score
inférieur de trois points par rapport au
scrutin de 2015 le rassemblement
national passe de trois à deux sièges
yvelinois au conseil régional conseiller
sortant l'ex maire de mantes la ville
cyril note ne se maintient donc pas dans
l'assemblée il faut pour lui se mettre
d'ores et déjà au travail en vue de la
présidentielle
les sortants ont été assez facilement et
brillamment regus est une réalité on en
prend
va falloir évidemment créer une
dynamique puisque l'absence de victoire
prive de cette dynamique pour lancer la
présidentielle c'est à marine le pen de
bien travailler sur ça sur sa campagne
sur la manière dont elle va aller à la
rencontre des français dans quelques
mois du côté de la république en marche
les succès de l'année 2017 avec la
présidentielle et les législatives
semblent bien loin la liste conduite par
laurent saint martin se positionne
dernière de ce second tour des élections
régionales en ile-de-france 9,62 % des
suffrages trente mille bulletins de
moins qu'au premier tour
un an après le scrutin des municipales
la majorité présidentielle confirme ses
difficultés à s'implanter localement une
dynamique qui prend du temps les
présidents et présidentes certain qu'on
sortait aujourd'hui ont souvent passé
beaucoup de temps dans l'opposition
c'est vraiment important de bien avoir à
l'esprit c'est à dire qu'une
implantation locale ça prend du temps et
je sais que vous êtes habitué avec la
majorité présidentielle à ce concept
toutes les deux d'un coup eh bien
peut-être que ces scrutins sont là aussi
pour rappeler que une implantation
locale ça prend du temps et que c'est du
travail auprès des concitoyens et nous
franchissons aujourd'hui une belle étape
qui est celle de la création du groupe
de la majorité présidentielle la région
ile-de-france la république en marche
aura tout de même son groupe au conseil
régional avec 15 candidat élu dans les
yvelines le parti obtient deux sièges
pourvus par les députés jean noël barrot
et aurore bergé
pour cette dernière qui fait partie
désormais des 209 conseillers régionaux
c'est maintenant que débute l'ancrage
territorial du mouvement macro nist on
n'existait pas au moment des dernières
élections régionales et départementales
aujourd'hui on existe en a vocation à
durer et moi c'est aussi pour ça que je
voulais être élu et conseillère
régionale certains il aimerait que la
république en marche soit qu'un
épiphénomène une petite parenthèse de la
vie politique et qu'elles se referment
aussi vite qu'elle est arrivée
c'est ce que voudraient les partis
traditionnels mais les partis
traditionnels ils ont échoué pendant
très nombreuses années citons la
république en marche n'aurait pas pu
faire élire emmanuel macron à la
présidence de la république et je serai
pas députés aujourd'hui si droite et
gauche avaient réussi en échec
localement la république en marche et le
rassemblement national reste cependant
en tête des intentions de vote des
français à un an de l'élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
seraient bien au second tour du scrutin
selon un dernier sondage ipsos sopra
révélé ce 28 juin
nous passons maintenant au scrutin
départemental dans les 21 cantons des
yvelines les sortants ont été reconduits
le président sortant pierre bédier s'est
même offert une large victoire face au
rassemblement national son canton de
mantes-la-jolie et grégory canale a
suivi cette soirée de résultats dans le
canton de mantes-la-jolie ont rejoint le
second tour des élections
départementales de 2015 pierre bédier
faisait face une nouvelle fois cyril
note six ans plus tard le résultat est
le même
pierre bédier le président sortant du
conseil départemental en équipe cette
année avec la première adjointe de
mantes-la-ville nathalie pereira pour
ensemble pour les yvelines remporte le
scrutin contre l'ancien maire est reine
de mantes-la-ville en duo avec mathilde
andrew et pierre bédier améliore même
son score de 4 points par rapport à 2015
il récolte 70 05 % des suffrages
c'est une progression qui est assez
logique puisqu'on avait déjà progressé
au 1er tour tout cas c'est un grand
sujet de satisfaction pour moi à titre
personnel bien entendu mais pour mes
colistiers aussi et puis je penche pour
pour le nom toi parce que on va pouvoir
poursuivre comme ça avec cet élan la
mission qui est la nôtre de plus de 80%
à mantes-la-jolie c'est vrai que vous
connaissez le lien singulier que
j'entretiens avec cette ville que j'aime
de toutes les fibres de ma peau de mon
corps de tout ce que vous voulez et donc
voilà belle soirée belle soirée
électorale
en face de pierre bédier cyril lot de
composer le binôme du rassemblement
national avec l'ancien responsable
départemental du parti si mathilde
andrew est en tête dans trois des cinq
villes du canton au premier tour ils le
sont uniquement à buchelay après ce
deuxième tour les deux candidats
recueille 29 95 % des suffrages cyril
l'autre s'inquiètent du nouveau grand
chelem réalisé par la majorité sortante
de la droite et du centre au département
c'est raté oui mais voilà les rapports
de force sont assez semblables à ceux
d'il y a
6 en réalité un jeu note que la gauche
peu tannique des tapas rattrape fait pas
forcément beaucoup mieux comme quand
elle se retrouve face à un binôme de
droite ou de centre droit donc oui c'est
pas rassurant pour l'avenir
le département des yvelines
hystériquement de droite de centre droit
qu'il conserve une majorité dans ce
département ça ne choquera personne mais
qu' aucune aucun représentant de
l'opposition que ce soit à gauche ou
rassemblement national dans un
département qui compte plus d'un million
d'habitants
oui c'est pas rassurant pour la
démocratie une élection départementale
dans le canton de mantes la jolie où
l'abstention s'est distingué 71% pour ce
second tour soit quasiment 15 points de
plus par rapport à 2015 et le scrutin
n'a pas forcément dit son dernier mot un
ou plusieurs recours voire même une
plainte pourrait être déposée par les
candidats de la république en marché de
l'union de la gauche éliminée au premier
tour en cause des irrégularités
présumées
en attendant après sa victoire pierre
bédier sera bel et bien candidat à sa
réélection à la tête du conseil
départemental des yvelines a semblé
d'installation ce jeudi 1er juillet à
versailles
un nouvel échec en tout cas pour le
rassemblement national à des élections
locales dans les yvelines car à cette
défaite dans le canton de montres la
jolie s'ajoute aussi à la défaite de
bonnières-sur-seine célia garçons comme
nous l'expliquent le rassemblement
national miser sur une victoire dans le
canton de bonnières sur seine
mais c'est finalement le binôme patrick
stefanini et josette gens du groupe
ensemble pour les yvelines qui remporte
ces élections largement en tête avec 70
85% des voix contre seulement 29 15 %
des voix pour le binôme rn laurent
maurin et monique fureur moguérou on
écoute la réaction des vainqueurs on est
satisfaits forcément on a beaucoup
travaillé les résultats sont bons pour
nous c'est fantastique
dans le canton
non seulement nous gagnons mais nous
améliorons le score de 2015 pratiquement
2 7 points
alors ça s'inscrit dans une tendance
nationale
ça s'inscrit aussi dans une tendance qui
était qu'ils pouvaient se lire dans les
résultats du premier tour sur le
compteur de bonnières mais encore
fallait-il transformer l'essai 82% à
vous dans 65% à freneuse et 60% à
bonnières sur seine dans quasiment
chaque grande ville du canton
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines
arrive en tête il n'y a qu'à flacourt
que le duo est reine arrive premier avec
53,70 % des voix même dans les villages
où le parti de marine le pen est
normalement favori le rassemblement
national ne convainc plus une défaite
expliqué par le candidat est reine du
canton de menthe cyril note
ce scrutin a été marqué par une
abstention très forte dont nous avons
été particulièrement victimes donc
effectivement il est très difficile à
mon sens d'en tirer des enseignements
des duels ep y est reine des yvelines
ont donc tous deux été remportées par la
droite ce n'est pas une surprise pour
patrick stefanini la droite républicaine
lorsqu'elle travaille
lorsqu'elle fait campagne de manière
sérieuse lorsqu'elle s'appuie sur des
candidats qui ont à la fois de
l'expérience de la compétence et qui
parle aux électeurs de leurs problèmes
et bien la droite fait reculer l'extrême
droite
le taux d'abstention s'élève à 63 61 %
pour le canton de bonnières sur seine
c'était le canton où la gauche pensait
l'emporter celui de trappes avait vu le
maire de la commune arrivé en tête au
premier tour avec son binôme face à la
droite seulement la majorité sortante a
réussi à rattraper son retard
retour sur ce scrutin avec michael et
demi d'euros la droite conserve
finalement ce canton le trap arrivé
deuxième au premier tour des élections
départementales
le binôme sortant nicolas dainville and
capio conserve les deux sièges au
département des yvelines
ce dimanche 27 juin le duo totalise
52,17 % des suffrages
c'est ce point de plus qu'au premier
tour il devance le duo divers gauche aly
rabais anne-marie à bookish c'est la
victoire d'une campagne qui a été un peu
difficile avec nos amis d'à côté de
trappes
il a fallu qu'on se bat qu'on fasse
beaucoup beaucoup de terrain il a fallu
qu'on réveille un peu notre électorat
pour le deuxième tour on a réussi et on
est très content très heureux très
heureux de ce trail en équipe parce que
c'est vraiment grâce à toute l'équipe de
nos trois communes qu'on a pu gagner ce
soir l'équipe de trappes
l'équipe de la verrière l'équipe
d'elancourt qui se sont mobilisés parce
qu'ils ont cru en notre projet ils ont
cru en nos valeurs
ils ont cru renens notre volonté
d'améliorer les choses sur ces beaux
canton en tête au premier tour les
candidats de la gauche aly rab et
anne-marie bouquet termine finalement à
cette deuxième place avec 47 il ya que
83 % malgré une progression de plus de
1400 voix entre les deux tours
ce n'est pas suffisant pour espérer
reprendre le canton après l'avoir perdue
en 2015 mais le binôme échoué perd le
canton avec 500 voix d'écart et un score
de 69 57% dans la ville de trappes
je voudrais féliciter
mes adversaires qui ont réussi à
remporter à maintenir leur canton la
bataille a été rude
ils ont gagné plus largement lors de la
dernière élection ça a été très serrée
cette fois je ne doute pas que la
prochaine sera en faveur de la gauche et
qu'on l'a remporteront et je voudrais
également dire que je suis
particulièrement fier et honoré de la
confiance que m'ont témoignée
personnellement les trappistes en votant
à près de 70% pour leur mère au terme
d'un an seulement deux mandats la
participation sur l'ensemble du canton
est quant à elle en eau sur ce second
tour avec 29 points 30% et un être bon
attraper avec 27 26%
près de six points de plus qu'au premier
tour engagé sur ce canton le maire
d'elancourt président de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines jean michel
fourgous il est remplaçant du binôme
nicolas dainville un de capio et il est
forcément très satisfait globalement ce
canton c'est un des plus difficiles
devant nous mais on l'a gagné voilà prêt
à dire voilà pour la deuxième fois
donc voila quand on est prêt en tout cas
a relevé beaucoup de défis je les
connais bien ils sont porteurs
d'innovation je suis très fier
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai dû contribuer
certainement un petit peu à les aider à
gagner
écoutez moi je suis j'ai passé une bonne
nuit le plus grand canton du département
allait-il passer au vert c'était l'une
des questions hier soir de ses
départementale dans les yvelines avec un
bon score à l'issue du premier tour le
binôme écologistes pouvait nourrir des
espoirs et tenter de s'imposer sur les
terres du sénateur yvelinois actuel
président du sénat gérard larcher
mais le report des voix entre les deux
tours n'a pas été suffisant eléonore
sinoquet 61 52 % pour le binôme geoffroy
dax de keating clarisse de mon contre 38
48 % pour le duo david jutier patricia
milo les candidats europe ecologie les
verts n'ont pas réussi à faire vaciller
la majorité départementale sortante
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines a
conservé lors de ce second tour des
élections départementales le canton de
rambouillet ça a été compliqué mais
voilà on y est arrivés on a fait une
belle campagne je pense une campagne de
terrain où on n'a absolument rien lâché
on a été sur le dernier mois partout
dans les gares dans les marchés on a été
auprès de tous les habitants des suds
illinois et donc on est vraiment très
fier de cette victoire qui était pas non
plus actes et donc on est vraiment très
fier on aller chercher les voix une par
une
et donc maintenant ça promet le meilleur
lors du premier tour geoffroy vexe de
keating des clarisses demont était déjà
en tête dans ce canton du sud yvelines
mais les écologistes david jutier et
patricia milo n'était pas très loin
derrière laissant un espoir au binôme
entre déception et satisfaction c'est la
consternation devant l'abstention qui
dépasse encore ce soir les 60 % qui
restent à ce niveau record qui interroge
vraiment sur la légitimité des personnes
qui sont élus ce soir avec une
représentation aussi faible des
habitants et habitantes de la de la
population et puis évidemment
un sentiment de satisfaction parce que
élection après élection on consolide nos
scores et on montre que sur le sud
yvelines sur le canton de rambouillet le
projet politique qui est porteur d'un
espoir d'alternance de renouveau c'est
bel et bien l'écologie politique et ça
c'est la reconnaissance du travail qu'on
fait depuis maintenant 10 ans hurle sur
le terrain après l'annoncé officielle
des résultats pour les soutiens du duo
gagnant
lajoie s'est fait ressentir dimanche
soir comme pour le président du sénat
gérard larcher venus spécialement
félicité le binôme de p y
malgré l'abstention victoire très clair
une victoire très large dans toutes les
communes du canton d'une équipe dhabi
nom'' à la fois marqué par l'expérience
clarisse de mots la jeunesse
l'enthousiasmé le nouveau maire du
perray en yvelines
c'est je crois l'image que nous pouvons
donner à la reconquête aussi d'un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens qui
n'ont pas senti qu'il était important de
se déplacer et pourtant le département
c'est la vie sociale
le département ce sont des aînés le
département ce sont deux collèges le
département c'est l'aménagement de
routes au quotidien et je dois dire que
ce travail là il va falloir qu'on le
fasse encore plus demain
mais une très grande joie je suis ravi
des résultats puisque deux des candidats
font partie de mon équipe municipale
madame demont et monsieur gourland je
suis heureuse de voir malgré
l'abstention qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui
que de nouvelles personnes se sont
mobilisées objectif maintenant continuer
son action pour clarisse demont et
apporter de la nouveauté pour le tout
nouveau conseiller départemental
geoffroy dext keating pour la république
en marche ce scrutin aura également été
difficile avec une stratégie assez peu
lisible alliée à la droite le merde
où il emporte dans son canton vous le
voyez mes ailes en se présentant seul le
binôme et lrm échoue sur le canton de
versailles 2 écouter à la députée ma
chronicité yvelinoise marie lebey que
c'était dans l'émission paf
aujourd'hui sur notre antenne c'était
une élection compliquée parce que en
fonction des cantons ne vont pas partout
choisi la même stratégie aux municipales
et l'on sait bien que ça reste une
élection très numérique
les élections cantonales il y avait dans
des cantons dans plusieurs cantons et
dans plusieurs villes la reine qui avait
soutenu le maire aux élections
municipales
il était de bon sens de le soutenir en
vue des cantonales
sinon quelle logique ça aurait créé pour
notre électorat ce qui n'était pas du
tout la même chose par exemple reprendre
versailles 1 donc le canton il y avait
un binôme qui s'étaient déjà présentés
contre françois de mazières et donc
c'était aussi logique qu'ils y aillent
qu'ils tentent leur chance ils ont fait
un score qui est honorable également
avant de refermer cette édition tour
d'horizon des autres cantons et blinois
qui sont vos élus locaux les résumés
principales déclarations avec ce
reportage préparé par la rédaction de
télé 78 la gauche qui ne concrétise pas
dans le canton de trappes malgré son
avance du premier tour les verts qui ne
parviennent pas à faire de rambouillet
le premier canton écologistes des
yvelines le rassemblement national qui
subit de lourdes défaites à bonnières
sur seine et à mantes la jolie pour la
majorité sortante les bonnes nouvelles
se sont multipliées dimanche soir
certaines meilleures que d'autres avec
dans plusieurs cantons de véritable
plébiscite apprécié par exemple karl
olive et suzanne john hayes récolte plus
de 70% des suffrages
large victoire également de la majorité
sortante à aubergenville chatou limay
saint germain en laye sartrouville ou
encore versailles 1 et versailles 2
le chesnay rocancourt et saint cyr
l'école la stratégie de pierre bédier
payante a été payante c'est à dire
un centre un centre est et une droite
ouverte puisque nous nos candidats
n'étaient pas forcément l heure était
arrivée d'un modem avec je vois mon
remplaçant sur le canton 2 de villepreux
sacyr et bois d'arcy qui dit jean mathis
à munich
donc la stratégie était plutôt payante
c'est à dire une stratégie ouverte une
stratégie pas forcément fermé sur sur
des étiquettes politiques
on aura travaillé jusqu'au bout et parce
que les électeurs lui ai quand même si
le produit doit être prêt pour la course
avant d'avoir fini dans d'autres cantons
les succès de la droite et du centre
sont moins importants laissant des
regrets à leurs adversaires qu'il
s'agisse des mureaux de conflans sainte
honorine ou de plaisir voire de montigny
le bretonneux
on était c'est pour pour les habitants
effectivement parce que pas ce qu'on a
rencontrés en tout cas ils y croyaient
ils ont voté pour nous donc je pense
qu'il ya une mouvance effectivement qui
est en train de naître de renaître
et voilà il faut attendre peut-être
quelques temps pour que de nouveaux
puissent identifier une vraie gauche ici
son canton n'a pas vraiment douté parce
qu'on a fait une campagne où c'est
vraiment donner à fond et on a essayé de
retranscrire toute la
le bonheur est en tout cas l'envi que
l'on avait pas après c'est évident
qu'avec ce taux d'abstention là c'est
toujours compliqué on sait pas trop
comment les choses vont tourner mais on
était confiant sur j'avoue qu'une fois
on a un bilan solide
on avait une envie on a fait beaucoup de
choses je pense que on est très heureux
on avait dit que le canton de montigny
guyancourt comme de deux autres étaient
sans doute fragile et et pouvait
basculer ça n'a pas été le cas et au
contraire on a fait un score extrêmement
fort donc pour nous c'est a évidemment
une très grande joie et je salue aussi
dont candidats qui étaient en face de
moi françois morton parce qu'on a je
crois a essayé de faire une campagne
extrêmement digne et respectueuse et on
était d'ailleurs régulièrement au
téléphone ensemble pour essayer de caler
les choses et c c'est bien de pouvoir
faire des élections de cette façon là
est de montrer cette façon de faire les
choses allaient de la politique auprès
des habitants la droite et le centre
réalise donc un nouveau grand chelem
avec vingt-et-une victoires sur 21
possibles
mais de nouveaux visages si elles ont
néanmoins dans l'hémicycle qu'il
s'agisse de julien chambon sur wii ou
encore de fabienne devèze à verneuil sur
seine et de grégory gars restiez à
maurepas en 2014 je m'étais engagé
auprès de mes électeurs auprès des
habitants devant pas les moyens de ne
pas cumuler deux mandats parce que
c'était mon premier mandat de maire et
parce que j'estimais également que je
aussi je devais faire mes preuves je
devais m'impliquer pleinement aussi dans
ma ville et ce sera toujours le cas dans
les années qui viennent et je me suis
aperçu avec l'expérience maintenant que
le mandat de conseiller départemental
c'est le prolongement du mandat de maire
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est la
proximité et le terrain le mandat de
conseil départemental c'est des
compétences de proximité
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
consacrée à ces élections locales je
vous rappelle donc que sur le plan
départemental à la droite réalise un
nouveau grand chelem une nouvelle fois
les 21 cantons rpt est dirigée par le
micro parti majoritaire ensemble pour
les yvelines dirigeait donc par la
droite et le centre
on écoute pierre bédier président
sortant à ce sujet ça veut dire que
toutes les équipes
on était performante et ont su
convaincre les électeurs c'était plus
difficile qui a six ans dans la mesure
où ya six ans le président de la
république et m sur land que monsieur
hollande était extrêmement impopulaire
que la gauche qui a été ces fonds
devraient donc on avait comme on dit
vulgairement le vent dans les voiles
là on voyait même c'était plus compliqué
on craignait une montée du rassemblement
national
on savait pas trop dans un département
aux élections nationales
nos électeurs peuvent voter en marche on
l'a vu aux européennes comme on l'avait
vu à la présidentielle et aux
législatives
est ce qu'il est ce qu'ils allaient
faire comme à des élections nationales
ou est ce qu'ils allaient faire comme un
des élections locales
on avait vu aux municipales que
l'éthique est en marche n'avait pas
séduit donc il y avait quand même
quelques incertitudes mais globalement
ce département qui est un département de
modération reste sur cette ligne modérée
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv 78
merci au journaliste de la chaîne
mobilisés pendant ces deux scrutins et à
nos confrères de radio sensations avec
qui elle nous avait eu l'occasion de
travailler et d'échanger pour vous faire
vivre ces expliqué à ses campagnes
régionales et départementales demain à
18 heures retour de votre journal
quotidien avec grégory canal et très
bonne soirée
[Musique]
non